sauf qu'il y avait des mecs tout le long
de la rue avec des kalashnikov qui nous
ont criblé de balle pendant toute la
route donc les pneus sont éclatés mon
pote il conduisait vraiment avec son
volant comme il pouvait les pneus à plat
Camille Corsi c'est le genre de
journaliste nouvelle génération qui peut
aller en zone de guerre directement sur
le terrain pour ramener des images et
surtout une documentation mais aussi
faire des projets de cœur qu'on attend
pas forcément dans les documentaires des
journalistes je trouve son travail
passionnant elle est passionnante et
elle va nous raconter tout ça si j'ai
bien compris tu es donc la seule
personne qui choisit ses destinations en
fonction des bombardements qu'il y a
c'est pas tout à fait vrai quand même
c'est un peu c'est un peu réducteur oui
parce que je fais pas que des terrains
de conflit non plus hein j'ai réalisé
plein de documentaires en France ou
c'est des problématiques sociales ou des
portraits comme justement le portrait
d'une jeune fille sourte qui passe le
bac donc je ne suis pas que terrain de
conflit alors c'est vrai que j'en ai
fait beaucoup mais c'est pas
particulièrement les bombes qui
m'intéressent dans ces endroitslà et
c'est bien pour ça que je l'ai dit comme
ça c'est défiant exprès mais néanmoins
par contre le
le les terrains de guerre est-ce que ça
a été ta première envie ou pas alors de
guerre non moi vraiment mon rêve quand
j'étais jeune étudiante et jeune fille
que je commencéis dans le métier c'était
le grand reportage alors le grand
reportage c'est pas exactement la même
chose que le reportage de guerre on
estime que le grand reportage pour le
command est morortel entre guillemets
pour le grand public c'est vraiment
partir dans des zones compliqué d'accès
pour témoigner de choses à l'étranger
régulièrement mais pas que et moi c'est
ça qui me passionne mais c'est vraiment
arriver à accéder à des zones où très
peu de journalistes vont pour pouvoir
témoigner de ce qui se passe sur place
est-ce que l'idée c'est de montrer qui
peut presque s'approcher du voyurisme
pas dans le mauvais sens du terme ou
mettre un peu en application je je sais
pas comment tu tu tu vis ça toi le côté
on peut pas dire qu'on connaissait pas
maintenant parce que maintenant on
connaît c'est drôle je fini ma dernière
vidéo comme ça en plus la prochaine qui
sort sur ma chaîne euh c'est alors
évidemment en tant que journaliste il y
a forcément une part de voyurisme pas
forcément du côté négatif mais
évidemment il faut qu'on interroge les
gens faut qu'on filme ce qui se passe et
parfois bah c'est des choses très
intimes personnelles parfois c'est des
choses très dures très graves très
violentes malheureusement on est obligé
parfois de montrer des images ou des
témoignages comme cela pour pouvoir
sensibiliser le public et nous en tant
que journaliste on est là exactement
pour ça pour dire on ne pourra pas dire
qu'on ne savait pas en tant que
journaliste on ne peut pas changer laaré
d'une situation c'est pas parce que je
veux en Syrie témoigner de la guerre que
la guerre va s'arrêter demain absolument
pas par contre on ne pourra pas dire les
hommes et les femmes politiques par
exemple qui doivent prendre des
décisions parfois ne pourront pas dire
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'information
vérifié certifié sourcé par des
journalistes non on était sur place on a
témoigné et on a ramené des informations
vérifié c'est c'est notre job moi j'ai
un peu l'impression que des fois tu mets
des des émotions sur des mots tu sais
les les mots à force de les entendre on
les décharge un peu de leurs émotions le
mot guerre il est plus très impactant
quand tu dis il y a la guerre à tel
endroit il ce ce mot il est un peu
déchargé de tout ce qu'il y a derrière
quand on a toutes des images et des
témoignages ouais il y a il y a pour moi
ton ton métier au-delà de montré c'est
peut-être aussi de véhiculer des
émotions tu le perçois comme ça ou pas
du tout toi évidemment parce que
justement la différence entre le
reportage très court et le documentaire
il il sit tu là dans un reportage très
court on va pas avoir le temps de
s'intéresser aux personnes aux prénoms
aux gens qui y a derrière cette guerre
donc on va parler de chiffres il y a une
guerre en Syrie ça fait 400000 morts à
cet endroit-là il y a telle force en
présence nous le documentaire vraiment
s'éloigne de ça parce que on va rentrer
dans la vie des gens et pour que les
gens puissent s'identifier à ces
personnes là parce qu'on reste tous des
êtres humains sur cette terre et m de
rien on a quand même beaucoup de
ressemblance et c'est justement de
essayer de retrouver ces petites
étincelles d'humanité qui vont faire que
le public va dire ah mais ça pourrait
être moi qui est là en fait ça pourrait
être mes enfants qui sont sous la guerre
ça pourrait être mon fils qui est parti
se battre contre Bachar alAssad en Syrie
par exemple donc c'est ça le rôle du
documentariste c'est vraiment de toucher
dans l'intimité de la guerre pour
pouvoir le retranscrire et émouvoir les
gens parce que sans émotion il y a pas
de transmission d'information alors du
coup si toi tu fabriques un pont pour
qu'on ait les émotions ça veut dire que
tu es sur le pont pendant que tu
enregistres pendant que tu tournes
pendant que comment tu fais pour
absorber ça ah c'est une grande question
une question que tous les gens qui mais
pas que pas que les GL les humanitaires
aussi par exemple ou les militaires en
fait il y a trois professions en fait
qui sont sur le sur le terrain c'est les
militaires les humanitaires et les
jnaliste et vraiment c'est chacun a sa
manière de faire pour pouvoir gérer les
émotions autour de ça euh sur le terrain
ça va parce qu'on a une mission on est
là pour une bonne raison nous on a
choisi d'être là c'est pas comme les
populations locales qui subissent la
guerre nous on sait qu'on va rentrer
chez nous après et que et que c'est pas
notre famille qui est sur les
bombardement donc ça va sur le terrain
en général c'est pas le moment
l'adrénaline il y a tout ce truc où on a
la missionù faut vite rentrer enfin faut
vite rentrer les imagesou ouais nage
droit devant toioi c'est exactement ça
vraiment même quand on voit des choses
horribles si on est mine de rien je
pense qu'en tant que caméraman on est
vraiment protégé par l'appareil moi en
tout cas je le sens comme ça euh les
collègues de pressécrit parfois ont un
peu plus de mal parce qu'ils ont pas
cette distance que la caméra nous
apporte moi je vois toutes ces scènes à
travers leuton de ma caméra moi c'est
vrai que je rentre un maximum d'images
et après je fais le montage à Paris donc
la démarche est un peu différente et je
dirais que la gestion des émotions elle
est plus compliqué pendant le montage là
où on ressasse ces images et on doit y
faire face constamment ça dure longtemps
un montage de documentaire en plus donc
là vraiment moi ma recette c'est d'être
bien entouré c'est vraiment aussi d'être
entouré de person person qui font le
même métier que soi ou parfois on peut
parler en sachant que les gens
comprennent exactement de quoi on parle
parce que c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir
quand on reste par très longemps sur le
terrain un mois 2 mois 3 mois dans des
situations très complexes on devient un
peu schizophrène du jour au lendemain il
faut revenir à Paris payer ses amendes
répondre bascule à la vraie vie entre
guillemets quoi c'est là où c'est c'est
là où il est le choc en fait c'est ce
moment de bascule surtout quand on reste
longtemps vraiment où là il faut avoir
ces petites habitudes de reprise et il
faut vraiment être entouré de personnes
qui nous compr comen que des fois
quelques mots les personnes peuvent
comprendre ah elle a vécu ça elle a vécu
ça et le command est mortel parfois
c'est un peu difficile pour donc il faut
être bien entouré très bien entouré et
et puis avoir une vraie raison de faire
ce qu'on fait donc c'est ça qui nous
porte aussi quoi oui parce que quand tu
reviens ça doit paraître fadace genre
moi ma mère par exemple je vais la voir
et puis elle m'explique que la voisine
dis donc un nettoie mal ses fenêtres en
ce moment et ça ça doit te paraître très
très futile dans les premiers temps de
reprendre un peu le jeu de la société
quoi bah c'est ça alors sais que les
premières fois où je suis revenue de
terrain j'avais un peu de mal j'étais un
peu en colère contre ces gens qui se
plaignaient pour
rien mais avec l'âge et l'habitude on se
rend compte que benah en fait tout le
monde a le droit d'avoir ses petits
problèmes c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
gens qui meurent en Irak en Syrie au
Yémen que les gens n'ont pas le droit
d'être triste à Paris pour des fois des
très bonnes raisons d'ailleurs les
émotions sont vraies quoi qu'il arrive
exactement donc il faut avoir de la
patience avec les gens il faut voilà se
avec l'habitude on reprend enfin on
prend cette habitude de switcher et il
faut s'ouvrir aux personnes qui se Ret
de nous on peut pas se couper de notre
monde quand on rentre on peut pas être
désagréable avec tout le monde
soi-disant parce qu'on fait un tu te
rend pas compte mais non mais c'est ça
on peut pas être comme ça ou alors sinon
on va devenir aigri parce que en plus
moi je suis journaliste et je travaille
aussi en France et de problématiques
sociales qui peuvent paraître des fois
minimes par rapport à ce que je viens de
traiter avant mais non les gens ils ont
des problèmes et il faut s'intéresser à
à ces problèmes là qui sont réels en
fait et tu tu tu as déjà introspecté
pour voir si tu avais pas ramené un
petit syndrome post-traumatique de
quelque part ou ah ben je pense que de
toute façon tout le monde a un petit peu
hein j'ai envie de dire avec les
événements d'une vie on a tous des
petits chop exactement moi c'est vrai
que quand je reviens d'un terrain très
très chaud comme j'ai pu passer presque
un an mois par mois entre guillemets
différé en Irak c'est sûr que pendant un
an on suressaute un peu dès qu'il y a un
bruit sourd c'est sûr évidemment
forcément qu'on a des réactions
naturelles mais comme elles partent avec
le temps et que bon je fais pas de
cauchemar j'ai pas de problème l'air
équilibré ouais voilà donc je je ressens
pas le besoin vra c'est pas c'est ça a
été quoi ta dernière mission euh en
terrain de conflit vraiment ou dernière
mission que tu veux de de cette question
parce que bon en dehors de la terrain
métropole c'était Mayotte j'ai suivi
l'opération mouchou à Mayotte euh sinon
récemment en France j'ai traité des
enfants à la rue euh j'ai oublié aussi
oui j'ai travaillé aussi par rien à voir
sur les transports d'animaux vivants en
Espagne donc voilà c'est pour donner un
petit aperçu de de de ce que j'ai pu
couvrir là les de TR de tris derniers
mois
c'est fou tu vois parce que là je trouve
juste ce petit résumé de de la question
un peu floue ça permet de voir à quel
point tu navigues sur plein de spectres
différents en fait en réalité le le le
premier voyage qui a réveillé une
vocation chez toi si je dis pas de bêtis
à 21 ans c'est en Syrie tout à fait
pourquoi la Sirie ben on était en 2013
je venais de terminer mes études j'avais
mon DUT ma licence en poche et j'étais
basée à berout au Liban parce que je
très très nul en langue étrangère et je
voulais continuer à prendre l'anglais et
l'arabe et et bah clairement beyouth
c'est un peu le QG de tous les grands
reporters qui sont basés au Moyen-Orient
donc je pensais travailler sur place
mais ça pas du tout été possible parce
que j'avais pas de Cé d'adresse et pas
de contact et en fait un pote à moi me
file un contact à Halep la deuxième
ville du pays qui était vraiment ravagé
par la guerre civile à l'époque il me
dit quelqu'un peut t'éberger sur place
j'avis très peu d'argent donc quelqu'un
qui peut m'éberger sans trop de frais
parce que ça coûte très cher en zone de
conflit l'hébergement le traducteur les
voitures donc voilà on m'avait donné un
plan pour que je puisse y aller et bah
j'ai décidé que en fait à l'époque
vraiment il y avait que des images
faites au téléphone portable en plus des
téléphones portables vraiment très
mauvaise qualité on voyait des
bombardements au loin des scènes un peu
chaotiques de loin mais il y avait pas
de reporter vidéo il y avait de la
presse écrite et la photo mais il y
avait pas de reportage vidéo à l'époque
sur place et je me suis dit faut
vraiment que j'y aille faut que je
comprenne ce qui se passe sur place faut
que j'aille documenter ce qui se passe
sur place absolument je sais pas ça me
ça me transcendait quand vraiment ça te
prend au trip et tu sais c'est ça qu'il
faut que tu fasses absolument et donc
vraiment j'avais 400 balles en poche
parce que je vais des cours de français
à Beyrouth j'avais une petite caméra
vraiment sans microcanon avec une
batterie une carte mémoire pas de
trépied enfin vraiment le minimum vital
avec un ordinateur portable pour monter
sur Windows Movie Maker tu vois vraiment
on pouvait pas être en dessous non
c'était pas possible vraiment et j'ai
décidé bah voilà de de partir au sud de
la Turquie de traverser la frontière et
de partir à aleep où je suis restée 2
mois et en fait à la fin de ce séjour
j'ai pu vendre un reportage de 52
minutes à France 5 qui a été mon premier
documentaire pour la télé c'est
incroyable tu es tu es revenu différente
toi de ces deux mois forcément dans ton
état d'esprit professionnel dans ton
perso tu t'es dit ok c'est ce genre de
chos je suis faite pour ça pour pour
aller documenter en terrain de guerre ou
pas mais bah complètement parce que
c'est vrai qu'avant de se retrouver dans
un terrain de conflit on se pose
toujours la question comment je vais
réagir alors on peut se faire des
projections comme on veut dans sa tête
en s'imaginant une héroïne ou alors
quelqu'un quiit peur de tout peu importe
de toute manière la réalité elle va
arrivé au moment où ça va se passer euh
et j'ai découvert que j'avais pas mal de
sang froid alors je v pas dire j'ai pas
peur he tout le monde a peur à part les
gens qui sont complètement stupides la
peur c'est très bien c'estadrénaline ça
te permet de réagir rapidement à une
situation mais j'avais du sang frroid je
paniquais pas je me sentais utile
j'avais réussi à accéder à beaucoup de
choses à documenter énormément de choses
et j'aimais bien en fait j'adorais faire
ça et je me suis dit c'est vraiment ce
que je dois faire il y avait plus aucun
doute je savais que c'était ce métier et
d'un point de vue personnel évidemment
on grandit énormément quand on voit ce
genre de choses on fréquente des gens
qui ont le même âge que nous qui ont 20
21 ans qui eux sont depuis 2 ans déjà
dans les terrains de guerre qui nous
racontent leur quotidien et ça bah voilà
on perd une partie de notre naïveté on
perd une partie de notre notre enfant
intérieur peut-être qu'on retrouvera
plus jamais he une fois qu'on fréquente
ces zones là on verra plus le monde de
la même manière forcément on le voit
différemment mais on le voit
différemment ou on le voit pour de vrai
tu crois toutes les visions sont
réalistes c'est qu'une façon de voir le
monde en fait forcément la personne qui
qui qui ne bouge pas de son son quartier
ou de ou de sa ville il voit la réalité
c'est le monde qui existe autour de lui
mais disons que on a une vision
multidimensionnelle peut-être un peu
plus du monde ce qui des fois rend un
peu schizophrène aussi c'est toujours ce
côté un peu on a l'impression on a envie
d'être partout en même temps c'est c'est
très très très très dur à gérer comment
il
tes amis ou ta famille quand à 21 ans tu
dis ben voilà je vais partir là-bas
parce que j'ai une possibilité deux ou
est-ce que même peut-être tu leur dis
pas j'en sais rien au début j'aurais pas
annoncé parce que je savais que ça leur
bah créer beaucoup d'inquiétude je
leurais annoncé au moment j'étais à la
frontière turque à mes parents en fait à
ma mère et à mon père il se doutaiit que
ça allait finir par arriver parce qu'il
me connaissent donc ils savait très bien
que j'avais pour ambition de de partir
sur des terrains comme ça euh mais bon
ils avaient extrêmement peur il
préféraent être au courant parce que au
moins ça s'appelle un contact de
sécurité entre guillemets c'est que à ma
mère je pouvais lui envoyer un message
tous les soirs pour dire je suis bien
rentré tout va bien demain je pars à cet
endroitl et avoir au moins le contact de
mon traducteur parce que la Syrie c'est
vraiment un trou noir c'est-àdire que si
j'ai pas de contact sécurité et plus
personne la nouvelle de moi bah qui
est-ce qu'on va contacter il y a plus de
gouvernement central il y a plus de
police il y a pas de tu dispis mais
étrangère il y a rien donc faut qu'au
moins quelqu'un ait au moins un numéro
de téléphone ou une piste et que
toujours avant de partir sur le terrain
j'envoie un petit message à mon contact
de sécurité a priori je pars là là là là
je devrais a priori rentrer ces
heures-là s'il y a un souci de trois
autres numéros de téléphone de
personnees sur place je fais le petit
pousser bah oui il faut parce que ça
c'est une une erreur de débutant
normalement que j'ai un petit peu fait
finalement ma maman m'a m'a poussé à
faire ça pour mon premier terrain
aujourd'hui j'ai des gens qui sont un
peu plus capés qui peuvent le faire pour
bah voilà si vraiment je disparais qu'on
puisse au moins appeler le ministère des
affffaires étrangères il y a une
journaliste qui a disparu au moins
d'avoir une piste quoi toi tu étais
orienté mécanique oui je que 17 ans et
c'est quoi qui te fait basculer vers le
journalisme il y a quelque chose parce
que là il y a un pont quand même entre
les deux même si l'un peut être utile à
l'autre mais oui c'est en plus c'est
enfin moi je suis très contente d'avoir
fait la mécanique vraiment euh mais j'ai
c'était un rêve de petite fille je
voulais être depuis loin de plus loin
que je me souvienne je voulais être
photographe animalière sauvage dans la
forêt tropicale ok ok norement j'avais 4
5 ans je me voyais faire des aventures
avec mon appareil photo photographier
des animaux dans la forêt et bon
l'adolescence arrive ça me paraissait
tellement inatteignable de devenir
photojournaliste ou reporter que je me
suis dit bon on va faire comme tout le
monde on va essayer de faire un cursus
normal et et disons que j'étais une très
mauvaise élève à cette époque là et que
je me suis un peu fait virer de mes
lycées jusqu'à réussir à un peu ouais
pas totalement on m'a demandé gentiment
de partir on m'a pas viré on m'a demandé
gentiment de partir si é es d'accord
quoi
et donc je suis partie en mécanique
automobile un peu par défaut et
finalement ma mère a 17 ans que j'ai mon
bac à 17 ans me dit mais tu voulais être
photographe tu voulaisêre journaliste
viens on essaye on fait tout pour y
arriver la mécanique c'est clairement un
truc de médecin c'estàd j'analyse pour
trouver une solution rien que ce mode de
penser toi dans ton quotidien de de
journaliste c'est transposable en vrai
c'est une manière de penser qui est
intéressante tu vois tout à fait c'est
une manière de voir aussi un peu le
monde de différemment c'est du coup la
technique me fait pas peur il y a un
côté un peuon j'en ai tellement bouffé
couille mais au sens propre quoi
exactement bon après souvent on me dit
oui c'est génial tu peux réparer des
voitures sur le terrain non c'est pas le
cas parce que bon déjà ça fait 15 ans
déjà que je suis partie de mécanique
automobile et les voitures ont beaucoup
changé depuis désormais c'est plus
électronique que la mécanique hein
soyons soyons clair nous on bossait sur
des R5 des 205 ou des choses comme ça
les voitures de aujourd'hui bon on on
parle de voiture ça me fait penser à
quand tu as parlé de sang froid tout à
l'heure ouais c'est euh c'est quand que
tu découvres vraiment que tu as du sang
froid moi je je le raccorde à une
anecdote que que je t'ai entendu
raconter si tu peux nous la partager ou
peut-être c'est un autre moment mais
mais ça parle de voiture et de balles ah
oui oui oui c'est ma première expérience
du feu là on peut vraiment le baptême du
feu au sens propre j'étais encore à
beérout à l'époque he j'avais 20 21 ans
justement avant de partir sur mon
premier terrain de conflit donc
normalement le Liban Beyrouth c'est très
calme depuis des années mais de temps en
temps c'est le Moyen Orient en quelques
secondes tout peut basculer et ça c'est
vraiment propre à ces terrain là donc il
y a eu un attentat dans berou un général
des renseignements qui a été tué par un
attentat à la bombe et donc le soir même
il y avait énormément de groupes de
petites Milis qui étai dans Beyrouth
pour régler des comptes entre guillemets
c'est toujours ce conflit sunichi
ce cercle de vengance un peu inarrêtable
au Moyen-Orient et donc moi j'étais avec
des amis qui sont plutôt des gros teurs
parce que c'est c'est aussi un gros une
grosse place de fête he beyouth et on
partait simplement dans une soirée donc
vraiment on avait pas du tout des looks
de personnes qui étaient dans ces
conflits là donc on pensait qu'il y
avait pas du tout de problème on était
en centrville on était à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'ambassade
française donc pas du tout un coin qui
craint mais là au détour d'une rue on se
fait arrêter par un par un barrage de
jeunes palesttin en donc sunnite qui
nous demande de nous arrêter qui demande
les papiers à mon à mon pote qui était
libanais lui chrétien donc dreadlocks
rousse vraiment le mec qui est pas du
tout dans ces histoires là et manque de
PO c'est un chrétien mais qui est né
dans un village cheit et ça ça l'aura
pas plus donc ça a commencé à s'énerver
un peu le ton est monté bon je parlais
pas très bien Arab je parle pas t très
bien Arab d'ailleurs mais à l'époque bon
je comprenais pas exactement ce qui se
passé je voyais juste que ça commençait
à s'énerver et les mecs commencent à
ouvrir le coffre à taper sur la voiture
avec des barres de fer et mon pote qui
est au volant commence vraiment à
paniquer parce que ils ont peur qu'il
mettent il a peur qu'il metent une bombe
dans le coffre ou quelque chose comme ça
tout ça parce qu'il est né quelque part
ouais il a rien à voir avec ce qui se
passe vraiment c'est le mec lui il est
DJ c'est vraiment ils sont fou
complètement de de ces trucs là mais du
coup il accélère il brise le barrage et
il fonce parce qu'en fait au bout de la
rue il y avait l'armée libanaise et donc
on savait que si on était derrière
l'armée on était en sécurité sauf qu'il
y avait des mecs tout le long de la rue
a des kalashnikov qui nous ont criblé de
balle pendant toute la route donc les
pneus sont éclatés mon pote il
conduisait vraiment avec son volant
comme il pouvait lesu à plat tout le
côté gauche de la voiture a été criblé
de balle moi j'étais à l'arrière et il y
a même une balle qui a traversé vraiment
le coffre qui a traversé le siège
arrière et qui s'est enfoncé dans le
siège conducteur avant jusqu'à étit
ralenti avant de ressortir OK et coup de
chance moi alors je sais pas vraiment
infaction de seconde je me suis posé la
question qu'est-ce que je fais et je me
suis juste dit que qu' en mettant par
terre au sol de la voiture il y aurait
le minimum de surface de mon corps qui
était atteignable par les balles en fait
c'est tout ce que j'ai trouvé et j'ai
bien fait parce que sinon je pense que
j'aurais eu une balle dans le dos alors
c'est vrai qu'elle aurait été freinée
dans sa course mais bon ça quand même
fait des dégâts quand même donc voilà on
s'est arrêté après cette course est
freinée derrière l'armée libanaise et
vraiment on a mis 30 secondes à à
reprendre vie je pense on était un peu
tétanisé on nit pas très bien compris ce
qui s'était passé et vu les chocs et vu
le nombre d'impact de on s'est dit
forcément quelqu'un quelqu'un il y en a
un d'entre nous qui est blessé c'est pas
possible donc on avait peur de se
retourner de bouger les yeux à vrai dit
on avait peur de ce qu'on allait voir et
au final personne n'a été blessé
vraiment le miracle au total on a compté
17 balles de kalashnikov qui avait
traversé la voiture de pron c'est
incroyable en vrai c'est même mon pote
il y avait vraiment une balle qui a
ricoché sur la fenêtre conducteur ok
vraiment et c'était mais vraiment un
miracle vraiment on avait un ange
gardien j'y crois pas aux anges gardien
l'âge 20 ans ouais 20 ans ouais donc
c'était une première expérience et je me
suis dit mince j'ai bien réagi quand
même en une fraction de seconde je me
suis posé la bonne question je me suis
mis à terre et ça m'a peut-être sauvé la
vie ou peut-être que j'aurais été juste
blessé j'en sais rien mais tiens j'ai
des bons réflexes est-ce que ça pourrait
pas être utile autrement entre
guillemets quand tu étais allongé sur le
sol est-ce que tu étais en mode zéro
réflexion ou tu dis c'est fini on est
foutu
ou non ouais voilà ça duré 30 secondes
en tout maximum le moment où ça commence
à tirer le moment maximum 30 secondes et
toi tu as un film enti dans la tête du
coup là oui bah nous ça nous paraît une
éternité he par contre quand on est
dedans par contre quand ça tire ça tire
ça tire et qu'on arrive pas à l'armer on
a l'impression qu'il y a 2 heures qui
sont passé mais il y a quoi 15 20
secondes peut-être et là il y a pas de
pensée qui passe en tout cas pour moi ce
qui me concerne j'ai aucune pensée qui a
dans la c'est vraiment ça va directement
la moelle épinière vraiment
c'est ouais je pense qu'on est vraiment
là-dessus
du réflex animal pur et dur c'est
incroyable ce que tu racontes et je
trouve qu'en même temps c'est encore
plus incroyable de se rendre compte à
quel point la normalité elle bascule
dans un truc
ouais c'est un film là pour nous quoi tu
vois ça ça n'existe pas en temps normal
tu dis c'est ça bah c'est vrai que le
métoportage des fois ça amène à des
situations très particulières c'est
c'est un peu bon ce qui est difficile
dans notre métier ce que aussi génial
c'est qu'on est amené à vivre des
situations que personne d'autre ne
pourrait vivre entre mais je parle pas
du moment où on se fait tirer dessus he
mais ouais mais tu dois te sentir très
vivante après je pense oui oui oui après
on profite bien de la fête ouais tu
m'étonnes parce qu'une fois que vous
avez passé du coup que vous avez rejoint
l'armée libanaise là vous avez été pris
en charge et vous saviez que c'était
scure quoi bon on est pas pris en charge
du tout alors avait vraiment autre chose
à faire à ce moment-là ils étaient en
train de plutôt essayer de contenir le
mouvement ils avaient eux une fois qu'on
était en sécurité derrière eux c'était
bon non non bah après on a une voiture
bah il faut juste appeler la dépanneuse
quoi on appelle la dép Panneuse et on va
dans l'appart quoi on rentre à l'appart
en taxi il y a pas grand chose d'autre à
faire non est-ce que toi tu as préparé
ta mort potentielle mais je pars pour
moi je pars pas à la mort quand je parou
ouais non non mais tu vois tu aurais pu
te poser les questions enfin ça ça
m'intéressait de de savoir tu vois si
est-ce qu'on projette des trucs comme ça
de ça c'est pas mon cas c'est une bonne
question je m'étais jamais posé la
question à vrai dire bon jusqu'à
maintenant j'avais pas grand chose à
léguer donc franchement m ma moto quoi
mais mon vélo un peu plus maintenant
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'époque bah
j'avais rien donc bon déjà un
testament mais non j'avais même pas
écrit de lettres pour des proches ou des
choses comme ça après c'est pas
totalement vrai quand j'y réfléchi
maintenant que je creuse un peu ta
question c'est vrai que surtout à cette
époque là j'avais tendance à vraiment
tenir un carnet de bord précis et ça
pouvait m'arriver avant une journée très
très difficile de mettre un petit mot
pour mes pres au ça pouvait m'arriver
d'avoir deux trois lignes c'est vrai en
y repensant dans ces carnets là
peut-être est-ce que ça t'a arrivé de de
prendre un risque que tu considères
inconsidéré pour le coup juste pour
prendre des images pour capter quelque
chose alors tout dépend de quel de ma
vie tu parles parce que quand on est
jeune journaliste bah on a beaucoup plus
de mal à à peser dans la balance ok en
fait il y a un grand truc dans le
journalisme surtout ce type de
journalisme c'est qu'il faut toujours
trouver une balance entre l'intérêt de
l'information et le danger si c'est
extrêmement dangereux et que
l'information a aucun intérêt on y va
pas si l'information est un gros intérêt
petit danger on fonce et des fois on est
un peu au juste milieu
mal de danger l'info est quand même
super intéressante et là c'est à nous de
juger est-ce qu'on y va on y va pas et
quand on est jeune journaliste on la
connaî pas bien cette balance on a du
mal à estimer les risques on a du mal à
prévoir ce qui va se passer et on a du
mal à juger si une information est
vraiment pertinante ou intéressante donc
des fois on peut être amené à prendre
des risques inconsidérés par manque d'f
pas inconsidéré mais à prendre des
risques beaucoup trop poussés pour des
infos qui vont pas servir à grand-chose
en réalité mais on s'en est pas rendu
compte avec l'âge avec l'expri on a
beaucoup plus de recul on sait très bien
que les informations les plus
pertinentes elles sont pas en première
ligne pas du tout parce qu'au bout d'un
moment au bout de 10 ans bah on sait que
la première ligne bah c'est d'être des
mecs avec des calaches qui vont se tirer
dessus et en fait on apprend pas
grandchose parce que il y a pas de crime
de guerre à témoigner c'est des soldats
contre des soldats par exemple donc là
on est dans les règles de la guerre pure
et du en fait les vrais témoignages
intéressants pour les Ch c'est souvent
en arrière c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
avec les populations civiles c'est
surtout là où ça où il y a des
bombardements à certains endroits très
isolé ou des massacres dans des villages
ou des choses comme ça et ça c'est très
loin la ligne de front c'est pas
forcément les zones les plus dangereuses
qui peuvent être difficile d'accès mais
pas dangereuse et c'est là où on chope
les bonnes infos mais en tant que jeune
reporter on ne comprend pas ça on pense
que plus c'est risqué plus c'est
intéressant et c'est c'est très peu
souvent le cas quand quand on est face à
des combats ou je pense à la traversée
que tu as faite avec 260 migrants c'est
ça al je sais ça fait 10 ans je sais
plus combien on était ou 200 300 200 300
je sais plus exactement tu les avais
accompagné pour traverser la
Méditerranée donc rejoindre la France
est-ce queil y a des moments où où tu
lâches la caméra pour intervenir pour
aider en fait je me dis dans dans ces
moments-là est-ce qu'on arrive à se
contenir si on voit qu'on peut être
utile mais en même temps on est là pour
prendre un témoignage euh bien sûr mais
on peut toujours moi j'estime qu'une vie
humaine est plus importante qu'un
témoignage ou qu'une vidéo hein ça il y
a pas de débat à voir avant d'être
journaliste je suis humaine si si je
vois un enfant qui est en train de
couler dans l'eau je vais lâcher ma
caméra évidemment on va pas le truc
c'est que je me retrouve rarement seul
sur il y a quand même beaucoup de gens
autour donc j'ai jamais eu à intervenir
directement parce qu'il y avait des gens
qui étaient mieux formés que moi ou des
infirmiers autour de moi qui pouvaient
régler la situation ça ne servait à rien
que
j'intervienne mais ça m'est déjà arrivé
d'y penser par exemple tu parle de la
traversée donc je traversé avec des bah
des personnes qui qui sont sans papiers
qui voulent arriver jusqu'en France
depuis la Libye donc on est parti de
Zara qui est un petit village à l'ouest
de la Libye à bord d'un bateau de pêche
avec 200 300 personnes à bord donc au
des passeurs libiens autant vous dire
que ce sont pas des enfants de cœur
et évidemment je me suis posé la
question une fois que j'allais être à
bord de ce bateau si il y avait un
nafrage par exemple qu'est-ce que je
ferais et là moi j'étais avec un
collègue j'étais pas toute seule à ce
momentl on était deux en mission euh et
on s'est on en a beaucoup discuté et on
était pas d'accord justement là-dessus
parce que la boîte de production voulait
qu'on emmène une espèce de combinaison
gonflable là au cas où s'il y avait un
problème moi j'étais complètement contre
parce que euh la majorité des gens qui
sont en Afrique ne savent pas nager donc
si tu es la seule à flotter qui va être
la première à couler moi je me suis dit
tout le monde va s'accrocher à ce qui
flotte ce qui para logique la panique et
en fait ça je vais couler donc moi je
c'est à peu près bien âé je me suis dit
il faut mieux euh au pici naufrage
prendre un ou deux enfants sous le bras
et essayer de m'éloigner de la foule qui
va être en panique et essayer de sauver
au moins un bébé parce que je peux pas
prendre un adulte j'ai pas la force
physique mais je me dis c'est un tout
petit enfant je pourrais au moins
prendre un avec moi et pas couler ça
évidemment je lâche la caméra et je fais
ça en cas de naufrage bien heureusement
c'est pas arrivé comme ça donc j'ai pas
eu à à faire de tels choix mais siil
devait être fait bien sûr que je les
ferai ça c'est aucun doute non mais
c'est intéressant pour moi parce que ça
veut dire que c'est le genre de chose
quand même à laquelle tu as tu as
réfléchi en amont dans ces momentsl
forcément forcément et c'est toujours ce
qu'on dit il faut toujours un peu passer
en revue toutes les situations qui
puissent arriver parce que comme ça la
réflexion on a pas Besin de la faire au
moment où ça arrive oui c'est ça on se
des questions en amont comme ça on est
beaucoup plus pe per les pour les contes
et cetera tout savoir et après ne pas
être dans la décision au moment où faut
agir j'avais vu que un moment donné tu
avais sur une autre mission tu avais été
accompagné par l'armée pour ta
sécurité tu parles de la Somalie ou
Malie oui c'était en Somalie ouais c'est
c'est pas par l'armée c'est par c'est
par un groupe de militaire privé enfin
un groupe de sécurité dire d'accord ok
et je me demandais si ça t'avait aidé ou
desservi euh uneé d'avoir d'avoir des
personnes comme ça pour te sécuriser
excellente question parce que alors
c'est la première fois de ma vie la
seule et unique fois de ma vie où j'ai
eu une garde armée enfin une escorte
armée on appelle ça sous les conseils de
mon fixeur mon fixeur c'est un guide un
traducteur qui nous accompagne sur le
terrain qui en général c'est un
journaliste local ou un traducteur local
et la Somalie c'est très particulier
parce que en fait il y a pas de blanc
dans la ville amicho alors pour mettre
un petit peu de contexte pour ceux qui
savent pas il y a quand même les chebabs
qui contrôlent une grosse partie du pays
qui sont qui sont une branche d'alkaaïda
donc c'est quand même un peu tendu
hidnapp et tous les étrangers sont dans
le bunker à l'aéroport il y a beaucoup
d'étrangers des Chinois des Turcs des
Américains il des ONG mais il reste dans
un bunker à l'aéroport qui est une zone
internationale du moment qu'on sort de
l'aéroport on est seul au monde OK et là
on est vraiment j'étais la seule blanche
de toute la ville donc on est très
remarquable c'est vraiment même si je
suis voilé et compagnie on est très
facilement remarquable et comme il y a
un gros risque d'attentat et de
kidnapping mon fixeur a jugé bon qu'on
est une escorte armée avec nous mais
clairement si il y a euh un bataillon
des chebabs 10 20 hommes qui arrivent
c'est pas de mecs en calage qui vont
pvoir me protéger les pauvres ils vont
juste manger pour moi c'est et ce que
j'aime pas avec l'escorte c'est que
quand on se bat dans la ville au lieu de
sa petite Clio vite teinté circuler
d'aller dans personne ne voit qu'on
circule personne ne sait qu'on est là
bah là tout le monde sait qu'on est là
tout le monde c'est qu'on circule les
informations vont très vite dans ces
endroit-l il y a une blanche il y a une
blanche il y a une blanche et moi je
trouve que ça met en danger ça me rend
ultra ultra visible j'avoue je
réittirerai pas pour moi l'expérience il
s'est rien passé tout s'est très très
bien passé d'ailleurs mais
personnellement je préfère être discrète
aller rapidement chez des gens en qui
j'ai confiance et surtout aller vite
c'est-à-dire que dans ces endroit là on
arrive pour une interview faut surtout
pas s'éterniser ouais parce que il y a
les voisins qui parlent il a tout le
monde qui parle on sait pas qui est qui
donc le temps que l'formation circule
que les mecs se mettent en branle les
mecs arrivent il faut déjà être parti
c'est ça le secret en fait dans C endit
c'est pas d'avoir une escorte armée
d'ailleurs tu as dit on était repérable
parce que voilà la seule blanche et
cetera tu as jamais dit la seule femme
et et je crois qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de femmes que ce qu'on pense aussi sur
le terrain c'est c'est vrai ou pas ah
bah oui il y a encore 20 30 ans c'était
vraiment une profession très masculine
journaliste reporter ça a complètement
changé maintenant estce que vous avez
d'autres accès vous peut-être bah oui
c'est souvent ce qu'on dit parce que
mine de rien dans les pays musulmans
souvent bah nos confrères hommes ils ont
pas accès au côté des femmes nous en
tant que femmes on a accès aux hommes et
aux femmes et il y a un côté où on se
méfie beaucoup moins des femmes dès
qu'on est avec des soldat il y a
d'autres confrères hommes journalistes
ça peut des fois un peu la bataille de
coque de
testostérone ça peut être un peu chiant
parfois parce que voilà c'est des mecs
entre 20 et 30 ans qui aime bien se la
mesurer de temps en temps donc ça peut
ralentir alors que quand on est nana bah
personne se méfie de nous on n jamais
accusé d'espionnage on est il y a un
côté où nous je sais pas on nous voit
plus comme quelque chose de doux alors
ce qui est pas forcément vrai hein mais
bénéficier du bon côté des stéréotypes
là pour le coup pour le coup ouais ouais
oua ouais et moi je trouve que c'est pas
du tout un handicap un handicap d'être
d'être une femme sur ce genre de terrain
pas du tout au contraire ouis bah ouais
comment toi tu choisis tes sujets tes
sujets de cœur comme la colline du crack
par exemple pour les sujets français
j'aime bien toujours parler d'une
problématique qui a un lien avec moi où
je raconte un peu une partie de moi-même
aussi quelque part et là j'avais très
envie de traiter de la dépendance et de
la vision que la société a de la
dépendance de manière générale et à quel
point on criminalise les les les gens
qui sont dépendants à une substance au
lieu de les aider au niveau médical et
et en fait je pensais pas que ça irait
si loin parce que j'ai juste rencontré
des personnages sur cette sur cette
colline qui était merveilleux qui je me
suis beaucoup attaché qui bah comme la
jeune Laor qui avait 19 ans à l'époque
où je l'ai rencontré qui est aujourd'hui
maman de bientôt trois enfants qui est
complètement sortie du CRAC et que j'ai
beaucoup aimé suivre d'ailleurs que je
continue à suivre sur des années et ouis
la colline du crack mais il faut aussi
dire qu'à l'époque j'habitais quand même
à porte de clignancour pas très très
loin et que je passais devant tous les
jours et que je me disais c'est quand
même assez dingue je vais à l'autre bout
du monde dans des zones inaccessible et
je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a dans cette
colline personne n'y rentre personne ne
sait ce qui se passe dedans il y a des
êtres humains des êtres humains pourtant
qui y vivent il y a un côté curiosité
qu'est-ce que c'est que cet endroit et
il y avait vraiment une volonté vraiment
de témoigner de la dépendance et et la
criminalisation qu'on en fait en France
que je trouve pitoyable c'est c'est quoi
ton ta prochaine envie ton prochain
sujet ou celui que que tu es en train de
finaliser qu'on va découvrir bientôt
alors là euh je je retravaille un peu
mes 10 ans d'archive à la télé parce que
j'ai quand même beaucoup d'archives de
terrain de conflit qui sont incroyables
et à la télé on traite pas du tout les
sujets de la même manière et moi j'ai
plein de coulisses assez hallucinantes
que j'ai envie de ressortir donc ça va
être un peu des formats archives dont je
vais parler notamment le mes début en
Syrie dont on a parlé là il y a peu de
temps où en fait tous mes collègues se
sonent kidnappés sauf moi et et je me
retrouve à halepe la seule journaliste
donc ça je voulais raconter cette
anecdote entre guillemets qui avait un
peu chamboulé mon tout début de carrière
au bout de 4 jours je suis arrivé en
Sirie où je me suis retrouvé dans le jus
tout de suite après d'autres sujets je
dis sur Just la souffrance animale ù là
les Lutes écolos à la rentrée il va
beaucoup de dates notamment la 69 et
tout ça et moi j'adore couvrir gen
d'endroit parce que je trouve ça bah
justement on en parlait de hiérarchie de
l'information l'hérarchie des
problématiques et des problèmes sociaux
pour moi c'est ultra important de parler
des problèmes climatiques et et de tous
ces grands projets qui pour moi sont
dévastateurs pour l'écologie je trouve
ça ultra ant d'en parler parce que bah
ça se trouve enfin moi je je suis maman
ma fille elle n'ura peut-être plus d'eau
potable d'ici 30 ans ou 40 ans elle
n'aura plus peut-être de de de terre
arable de terre cultivable disponible
pour elle enfin moi je m'inquiète depuis
que je suis maman je m'inquiète beaucoup
plus de ces choseslà en fait et tu
projettes sur une génération plus loin
là et mine de rien c'est je pense qu'on
va se retrouver face à un murès dans
très peu de temps et c'est vra que là en
ce moment je m'intéresse beaucoup à ces
questions là je pense qu'à la rentrée je
vais être beaucoup là-dessus ok tout en
t'autorisant j'imagine des sorties ce
que j'appelle des sorties c'est par
exemple un documentaire que je
n'attendais pas du tout de toi et que
j'ai adoré regarder qui était celui sur
la famille sourde oui j'attendais
vraiment pas ça d'ailleurs d'une manière
générale dans la vie j'attendais pas du
tout d'information de ce côté-là et et
d'un coup on te la propose et toi tu es
ravi en fait de mieux comprendre ces
personneslà parce que justement je pense
qu'on attendait pas d'information parce
que on on les sortait complètement de
nos radars de vie tu vois ce que je veux
dire et c'était vraiment passionnant
merci pour ça d'ailleurs mais avec
plaisir et c'est vrai que la sururdité
c'est un handicap qui est complètement
invisible donc je pense que c'est un
handicap que les gens ne connaissent
très peu parce qu'on les voit on peut
pas peut pas voir si une personne est
sourde dans la rue c'est pas comme les
gens aveugles ou des gens qui sont
physiquement handicapés c'est surtout la
rencontre avec cette famille en fait qui
m'a décidé à faire ce documentaire parce
que la famille crève tellement l'écran
ils sont tellement incro incroyable ils
sont solaires il y a cette jeune fille
qui a une volonté incroyable alors que
franchement l'éducation nationale
franchement vraiment ils font ils font
rien pour l'aider parce queil y a pas de
traducteur la moitié du temps il y a
plus d'institut spécialisés quasiment on
les met alors maintenant on les mélange
avec des élèves dis normaux entre
guillemets mais le problème c'est qu'il
y a aucun moyen pour les professeurs de
donner accès au cours quand tu n'entends
pas le cours et tu ne sais pas lire sur
leslèvres et qu'en plus c'était pas le
covid en zoom c'était un enfer a réussi
à avoir son bac heureusement mais
c'était aussi un énorme défi technique
moi qui tourne 99 % du temps seul sur le
terrain je me suis rendu compte que bah
je pourrais pas parce que il faut
forcément le champ contre champ pour
avoir une conversation entre deux
personnes qui parlent la langue des
signes sinon le temps que je tourne la
caméra bah je rate le début de la phrase
de l'autre et compagnie donc c'était il
fallait forcément être en bicam il
fallait qu'on ait un iné son parce que
comme il y avait aucune voix il fallait
que le son soit nickel parce qu'il y
avait aucune voix à aucun moment et on
avait une traductrice en direct qui
passait par l'ingestion la mi de la
gestion qui neous traduisait tout en
direct dans l'oreillette pour que je
puisse poser mes questions de manière
assez fluide et naturelle en fait pour
pas qu'il ait une traduction de 3 He
après mais j'ai dû remettre en question
toutes mes habitudes de tournage aussi
le fait qu'on puisse pas faire de plan
serré jamais parce que la langue des
sing ça se fait vraiment au niveau du
buste et donc il faut tout faire en plan
moyen constamment ce qui est assez
frustrant quand on est quand on est
cadreur et aussi merci quand même BR
parce que je CIS qu'il y a aucun autre
diffuseur à la télévision par exemple si
je proposais un projet sur une famille
sourde 40 minutes sans voix ouais mais
ça aurait été non tout de suite ils
auraient voulu mettre une voix derrière
ils auraient voulu comme on fait pour
les langues étrangères en télé qui est
un VoiceOver qui qui parle à leur place
pour leur donner une voix et moi je
voulais pas leur donner une voix non non
je je voulais les laisser parler avec
leur langue maternelle en fait
s'exprimer avec leur langue maternelle
et justement ce silence qu'onaccepte
plus beaucoup dans nos sociétés
aujourd'hui qui sont toujours très
dérangantes c'est que moi au début quand
j'ai eu cette famille on est très
dérangé par ce silence qui a constamment
on aime bien remplir le vide et en fait
je trouve ça super apaisant je pense que
dans le documentaire on arrive à le
retranscrire c'est qu'au bout d'un
moment on accepte qu'il y a pas de voix
on se pose et et ce silence jeement qu'
fait du bien voilà et ça ça c'était une
idée à toi que tu as proposé à brud du
coup ouais tout à fait ouais ouais ouais
en fait la jeune fille et oosen elle
faisait elle participait à beaucoup de
manifestations de Sour en colère OK et
il y a un autre collègue qui s'appelle
Rémy Buisine à brut qui l'avait
interviewé en live quand elle avait 16
ans en tête de manif elle a étit
incroyable a crevé l'écran et tout avec
mon enqu TR on s'est dit tiens cette
année elle va avoir 18 ans c'est l'année
du bac est-ce qu'on mettrait pas un
petit message parce qu'on peut pas
s'appeler ave des personnes sour donc on
communique par message en sachant que le
français c'est une langue étrangère pour
eux ouais euh donc c'est des fois c'est
pas évident de communiquer même par
écrit et effectivement elle passait son
bac et la famille était super partante
pour que bah je les suive pendant
plusieurs mois alors pas tous les jours
évidemment j'étais là des dates clés euh
pour son anniversaire quand elle fait la
teuf moi j'adore j'avais jamais imaginé
qu'il puissent avoir des tefs avec que
des sours et c'est des gros teffurs mais
c'est des énormes teur et ça j'y croyais
pas du tout et c'est génial les fêtes
des S franchement ils sont ben merci
pour tout ce que tu fais ben merci
beaucoup très cool merci merci de
m'avoir
[Musique]
invité